Speaker 1: So the failed former president Donald
Trump has been caught in another lie thanks to
some newly released audiotapes. From related
to Maggie Haberman, his forthcoming book. These
are audio recordings of interviews that Maggie
Haberman from The New York Times did for this
book that is forthcoming. And in this first clip
that we're going to look at, Donald Trump tells
Maggie Haberman he didn't watch the Trump riots
on January six, 2021 on TV. He wasn't watching it
as it unfolded. He eventually heard about it from
other people and much later turned on the TV just
for a moment. Now, of course, we know that this
is a lie. Multiple Trump aides testified before
Congress under oath that Donald Trump was watching
the entire thing. And of course, it's logical that
he was he went to the Capitol, gave this wacky
speech. People immediately started walking to
the Capitol. He wanted to go to the Capitol.
He was instead brought to the White House.
And he sat there watching TV the entire day. But
needless to say, he tries to lie here and say, No,
no. It wasn't that interesting, though. Someone
had to tell me about it. I was busy doing what? He
hadn't been doing work for months at that point.
Speaker 3: But what were you doing when you
how did you find out that that there were people
storming the Capitol? I had heard that afterwards.
And actually on the late side, very late.
Speaker 1: Very late.
Speaker 3: I was I was having meetings.
I was also with Mark Meadows and others.
Speaker 1: By the way, the mention of Mark
Meadows makes it even less believable,
because we know from the testimony of multiple
other witnesses that Mark Meadows was a 110%
engaged with the riots, begging Trump to do
something and in touch with Cassidy. You know,
all these the mention of Meadows makes this even
less believable. It was already not believable.
Speaker 3: I was not watching television.
I know the television. You weren't okay.
I didn't usually have that. The television
on. I'd have it on if there was something.
Speaker 1: And of course, that's where Trump
goes too far. Trump had the TV on all the
time. In fact, he would sometimes have it on
during meetings and it would distract him.
Speaker 3: I then later turned it on and
I saw what was happening. I also had a.
Confidence that the capital who didn't want these
10,000 people capital police who that they'd be
able to control this thing. And you don't realize
that, you know, they they did lose control.
So what Trump says there, it just wasn't
true on two fronts, that there were aides
around him at that time who have testified to
the House Select Committee that he indeed was
watching television. During that period. He
would have seen the Capitol falling to his
supporters. And also the Capitol Police were
clearly overwhelmed by the Trump supporters.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So it's all lies. And we've we've
talked about it. There's widespread reporting.
Reuters Trump Watch January six Capitol Riot
Unfold on TV Ignored Pleas to call for peace.
The entire day afternoon was Trump watching it
and then initially thinking that it was great
and then later people urging him to do something
about it. Trump starting to become upset that the
rioters were coming off as so low brow. They
didn't exactly seem like high class people was
a concern for Trump as that was going on. And we
know that it was all lie after lie after lie. Now,
there's one other clip here. This is pretty
interesting. Now, in the context of the
Mar a Lago raid, Donald Trump was asked about by
Maggie Haberman in these recordings about taking
stuff from the White House. And it's all just
kind of weird. The language is weird, again,
Asian, that you had with Donald Trump, where
you brought up the correspondence he had with
North Korean leader Kim Jong un. New York
Times released audio of this that we have
audio of this conversation. So let's listen.
Speaker 3: Did you leave the White House with
anything in particular, any memento documents
you took with you? Anything? No. Nothing of great
urgency. Okay, I am going. Things are,
you know, the letters, the Kim Jong-Un
letters and many of them. You were able to take
those with you. Look at what's happening now.
Speaker 1: Those are the love letters.
Speaker 3: I think that has the I think that's in
the archives, but most of it is in New York. Okay.
But the Kim Jong un, where been incredible. These
I have incredible letters with other leaders.
Speaker 1: Okay. So at least there Donald Trump
not admitting that a whole bunch of different
stuff was taken and it was at his house. Of
course, that interview was from that interview
because it was from about a year ago. And so that
is something that is particularly interesting
at this point in time. Wild stuff. But even in
private conversations, Trump lies because
Trump lies all the time. And we know that.